Okay, so let's go into some more details on
Cloud Endpoints. You probably remember this picture from lesson
two, where we introduced Cloud Endpoints, and where we
described this capability to create one API that you
could use to create client applications for many different
devices. Well you may wonder now, why is Cloud
Endpoints any different from a pure HTTP protocol? For
example, a REST API. Well, let's look at that.
When using Cloud Endpoints, it allows the development
environment to inspect and be aware of your
API. This has multiple values. First of all,
application design. When designing your backend application, you can
focus on the high level application design and
you don't need to think about low level communication
syntax and semantics. Cloud endpoints also performs native
client library generation for a number of different languages.
This helps out greatly, with a number of
different things. For example, communication and establishing connectivity and
error management, so you don't have to deal with
low level communication errors. But also, higher level functions
such as user authentication that we use for Conference
Central. And also, since your API can be expected,
Google can provide many tools around it. The API
Explorer is just one example of such a tool,
which is extremely useful. So Cloud Endpoints is a
great way to develop APIs that are rock solid,
easy to use, portable across devices and languages. And
can be used with tools, such as the API
explorer. Great value here in other words, since it
let's you focus on your app and let Google
take care of all the low level details. Let's
now look at cloud endpoints in your development environment.